welcome back for another Collider
interviewed Sundance 2019 brought to you
by the Kia Telluride thank you to them
because it gives us the opportunity to
talk about great movies like animals and
I'm so excited I was already telling you
before I love your movie so so much it
just saw it at the perfect time for
myself where I identified with those
characters a little too much but it
really kind of touched me in the end so
thank you guys for coming in to start
here just because nobody out there knows
what animals is just yet or at least not
many of our viewers even though the
source material is out there so Emma
would you want to start by giving a
brief synopsis of your movie sure okay
and so it's about two friends who've
been friends for about 10 years they
live together they've been Wilding it
around town and then one of them falls
in love not only with with someone else
but a teetotaler and to use that word in
the state's teetotal it no okay someone
who doesn't drink you say it again
teetotaler someone who doesn't drink and
so obviously that's a big threat to the
relationship is a big threat to their
friendship but also it's the creates
tension in their lifestyle because it's
so radically different from the way that
they've been living together as friends
so so yeah so it's about kind of how
that how those both both those
relationships are going to work out with
the with the new fella and with yeah the
old friendship and just kind of yeah and
for you Sophie it's been a little while
since your last film so why now for
animals and also it's one thing to say
I'm gonna go out there and make a movie
it's another thing to actually get the
feeling like it's really gonna happen so
what was that specific thing that really
got you going or got a green light hmm I
mean I read in this book and I just
thought it was beautiful I I really
connected to with it as well and I felt
I was seeing characters that I just
wasn't getting to see on screen and for
me you know that exploration of being a
woman and those competing desires that
happen as you're trying to work out what
you want to be and certainly the idea of
seeing a friendship you know on screen
that isn't
really romantic and celebrating that in
some way I was really drawn to all of
these elements it actually took us a
long time to finance that though we
worked Emma was writing the the
screenplay already and then we worked
for three drafts after that I think and
it just took a lot to get it up you know
it was like all indie films you know it
was a labor of love and I didn't even
really know it was going to go and I
remember getting on like thinking are
you someone said to me you need to go
and get on a plane to Dublin and shoot
because we shot it in Dublin and I
thought won't God if I'm going that's it
I've just got to go and do it so packed
up our whole lives went over to tell
them for three months and and luckily it
went we kept him and stuff like oh
there's already another movie about
women behaving badly and stuff you know
just kind of like all like we had a
movie we had a movie a few years ago
about women about young women that's it
that's the only chance like well I'm
happy it worked out and that we're
sitting here right now as I cover my
microphone I want to also talk about the
audition process here because you to
have such an infectious chemistry and
I've seen so many roles of yours where I
think I mean in particular for some
reason the final girls is coming to my
mind right now just where female
friendship is so prominent so one what
was the audition process like for you
two and was there any sort of chemistry
read happening to make sure that you two
were the perfect pair for this
definitely didn't audition them I had I
just I appeared the role and they're
both you know I was it was it was total
privilege for me to have to be able to
work with both of them so we had some
Skype calls and talked just to make sure
that we were on the same page but you
know I'm a big fan of both of their work
so it was an easy choice yeah and then
how was it jumping in for the two of you
it was a like meeting for the first time
great we were just
I was really drunk I'm a yes it was
straight in the defend and it wasn't
like a new place that neither of us were
you know from or familiar with I mean
you had been to Dublin before but it's
really nice when you get to do and we're
playing characters who've lived in this
town and like kind of owned it in our
own way so it was fun to get to discover
you know like bars that we'd be shooting
in later Sophie would be like you guys
should go get a drink there so we get to
like live out the experience together by
discovering Dublin as like new friends
so like you're learning a lot of new
things really fast and meeting new
people together as well yes so that was
kind of cool meeting a city and meeting
people and kind of finding our feet
together like as mates together so
really nice touch to have had I know the
characters grow a lot over the course of
the film but both of them have really
admirable qualities that they come to
embrace towards the end so just
wondering if you could kind of keep one
characteristic of each of them for
yourselves what would it be I think
about how people view or maybe in some
ways but she just kind of goes for it
and that's a nice quality not in every
scenario you know you have to choose the
setting but um yeah like that she's kind
of like goes for it she's like we might
die tonight like let's go
um instead of being like no I shouldn't
so I like that quality about her bulls
and Nora's tenacity I think she's got
there's a yeah she's got like a steely
bone in her solid pairing there for the
actual shooting process here was it a
stick to the script vibe or did you get
to play around a little especially in a
space like the apartment you guys share
it just feels like everything moves
around so fluidly that I imagine
blocking that out to a team might be a
challenge apartment was so gorgeous but
it was actually a big old like rambling
place huge that students have any power
it was crazy to shoot in it was really
common built into it that incredible
apartment and so it was really cold so
it wasn't as free as we liked I mean
these guys are very free natural you
know actors so they were definitely
drawn to doing certain things and then
we would go with that you know we would
just take that on and it wasn't
improvised though we did rehearsals and
that was playful we experimented with
things but the script is is pretty tight
and so we used that and just tried to
find ways to make it as natural as
possible and I would totally just watch
little vignettes of them doing I mean
like just going out for a random night
that isn't even part of the span that we
see them in in this movie another thing
that I was hoping to ask you guys about
is just this idea of I mean you're four
incredibly talented women sitting here
right now and just what it means to be a
kick-ass group of ladies here at
Sundance celebrating a film that is all
about just embracing what makes you you
and coming to accept the good qualities
about yourself feels good especially
when you put it that way great coming
onto this for me because I've never
worked with so many women on one project
I mean it's rare that I've yeah or maybe
you just once before and it's something
really freeing about that this kind of
like there's a extra sort of I don't
know compatibility that you kind of I've
never noticed wasn't there before and it
was so it was a real kind of privilege
and quite inspiring to work with you all
you know one day we were kind of talking
about this earlier obviously it's become
you know more popular and rightly so to
be like we need more female filmmakers
to most stories but I'm also like oh I
hope one day to be able to look back and
be like yeah that's one they kept
calling his female filmmakers instead of
just filmmakers like that's what he was
still kind of a new idea and now we're
not just it's not just like yeah this is
a great film it has to be specified so I
look forward to that time and feel proud
to be a part of this time where we're
like yeah I guess we still have to
preface it but to us is just the stories
that we're used to and want to see more
of it's so true I mean every single time
I say it when I'm covering a story about
a female director signing on for
think it feels like an obligation right
now and an obligation to put out there
to inspire that change but hopefully I
decided we're gonna say male filmmakers
we're like which which sounds so wrong
to me right yeah because they're like
well that's just the normal
that's just neutral that's it that's the
blank level the playing field yeah as it
should be and films like this will
definitely pave the way to hopefully
getting us there very very soon so a
Collider we play a little game called
would you rather and it's all about
moviemaking questions but today we're
gonna spin it a little and do some
Sundance questions so first would you
rather get to see your movie before its
big premiere or going completely blind
do you like watching the stuff that
you're in or does that make you
uncomfortable at all cuz I know it
varies from person to person yeah I
don't like hate it but I have a hard
time watching anything more than twice
so I'll see it like alone intimately
just like scratching my head and then
with the group see it audience and then
I'm kind of like goodbye yeah I had
whether to see it beforehand or not and
and so Brocklehurst the producer who
originally optioned it she said okay you
just wait till the premiere cuz I come
on the full thing you know I won't like
the big theater I was gonna wait because
I was like I don't want to just see it
on a link on like a laptop or something
and she said okay that's fine and then
just before Christmas she said look I've
taken advice on this Emma and you need
to see the movie or you're going to be a
mess gonna be an emotional wreck and
you're not gonna be able to like speak
it's you know wherever we end up burying
and she was right so it's just me and
her that saw it in the end and that was
actually good because I just had chance
to digest it now before it's the whole
the kind of anxiety obscene in a room
with loads of other people like how they
can I take it what's the bite gonna be
so so yeah I'm glad I saw it I wouldn't
like it to play without these guys
having having not seen it like they need
to see it otherwise it would be very
uncomfortable for me to show them
themselves in front of all those people
you know and we're all very revealed on
a film like this you know so these guys
are on screen but Emma and I behind the
camera you know we were revealing
ourselves and it's a very vulnerable
thing to do and I think you want to come
in at the premiere like it's a
celebration and so you get to have that
beforehand yeah interesting to look at
it that way
would you rather walk around Sundance
with no gloves or wet boots wet boots is
torture I was thinking about that
question as I walked back to my
apartment last night with no gloves and
then I started to rethink my answer
which was no gloves
would you rather meet a new collaborator
at a film festival or reconnect with
someone you worked with before both
sound like yes would you rather do
festival interviews with a co-star who
talks too much or not enough - too much
okay filmmaking one for you would you
rather mess up every single take
yourself or have somebody else mess up
your best take I'd rather have someone
else mess up just take the pressure away
feeling guilty the problem yeah would
you rather have to laugh or cry in a
scene would you rather have to do you
rather have to drink a lot in a scene or
run a lot in a scene oh you can I be
drinking water in the same somebody mean
you can be drinking anything you want
right like you if you do this scene ten
times over you have to keep drinking I
mean I probably feel better after the
running but I'd say drinking probably
I'm gonna have to say running actually
it's like he's at least you'd feel awake
after and not if it was the drinking
after especially anything but would it
have to be the end of the day otherwise
think about often when I watch a movie
with the certain activities that your
character is engage in is what exactly
are you drinking the entire time is it
food coloring and water or juice a nice
tart juice yeah we did by the end we
were asking props that if we have white
wine in the scene can it be like a
really nice Claire one like a really
clean crisp Pinot Grigio not a lot of
apple juice apple juice everything was
like real sweet yeah yeah and then you
just like give me a real drink you know
by the end of it and they take a lot of
drugs as well and that was candy candy
chopper Jones yeah candy it just sounds
so unpleasant to me last one would you
rather attend a festival with a crowd
pleaser or a more challenging film even
though here I think you actually fall
into both categories
yeah do they have to be separate freak
anyone out maybe like a challenging one
because if it's a crowd pleaser I don't
know it'll be out in other places and
stuff but something about challenging
one because I've had lots of challenging
films of Hell festivals and it's just
really interesting to see how people
react to it's always surprises you
whether it's positive negative or
somewhere between it's more fun as a
filmmaker if it's a challenging one
because you're you're answering
questions you're engaging really with an
audience and it's one of the few places
you get to do that is that a film
festival it's very different from going
to a multiplex or whatever and seeing a
film I think that's the perfect place to
wrap up here at Sundance 2019 thank you
guys so much for coming in cute again
love the movie guys keep an eye out for
animals like and share this video thank
you to Kia Telluride we'll see you soon
with more Sundance coverage
you